good morning everyone the time being
sessions okay first up I'm going to open
the work session on cacr
18 represent of
PL I'm not in favor of this at all
there's a long history of churches uh
receiving tax deductions uh uh since the
country's been founded essentially and
uh they do a lot of good uh for whatever
the denomination they do tremendous
amount of good uh in social welfare
helping people taking care of the poor
the Indigent U and uh uh providing the
help where it's needed and if this were
to pass a lot of churches would have to
close and so it it it were we're the
least Church station in the nation now
and it's going to get worse than that
and uh some people say well the
separation of church and State there's
never been separation of church and
state there's a there's a a constitution
in the Constitution it says the
government shall not interfere with
churches that doesn't mean churches
can't Thrive and so the government
should be helpful even-handedly helpful
thank you okay anybody else yes
representative
fellows so the way that I look at this
I'm I think that um it doesn't need to
be a constitutional amendment uh at some
point we might want to look at tax
exempt Charities taxes you know
Charities that are exempt from property
tax but we should do it as a as a whole
look at the at the whole thing and not
just specifically look at
Ames
oh
my
ex
don't thank you representative
Southworth I do see your microphone this
time great thank you Mr chair um would
you Contin consider doing straw Poes on
some of these it might be a quick way to
sure yes represent ORS yes my concern
would be the burden that would put on
the public system somebody would have to
step up and feed people clothe people
house people temporarily so these
churches are doing uh the public a
service our communities a service and I
think it would put an undue burden if we
tax these
churches it would put a burden on the
public to meet the need because a lot of
these churches as we know operate on a
Sho
string and uh I I think we would drive
them right out of out of business thank
you thank
you I guess I I can confirm that uh my
own church being a small Church um would
be deeply hurt by this and um many other
Church small churches yeah they're just
barely surviving and this would probably
be the death now for them um not to
mention you know larger churches do do a
lot of community outreach and and help
from what I've seen and um it's just
somebody's going to have to pick up the
slack um so it's it's it's not really
solving anything in my opinion
either um I guess to representative
southworth's
um point we could take a quick straw
poll um how many is there anybody for
this um
cacr
okay seeing none I have assume everyone
sitting here is is against it um is
there anything else anyone would like to
cacr okay
see yes yeah I think the proper motion
when we get to it is an itl not not an
interim study or anything else an itl
okay um with that I'm going to close the
work session on cacr
we'll now open the work session on HB
1191 I'll be forward again represent
plat to me this is has Merit it would uh
remove the rooms and meals tax for
participants in the restaurant Voucher
Program which is part of Meals on Wheels
and that that program gives senior
citizens some social uh uh exposure they
otherwise might be C up and not have and
it's a wash because instead of charging
$13 for a meal to include the tax it
charge $12 a meal but on the other hand
they turn that the that program turns
around and builds the state and they'll
build the state for $12 rather than $13
so it's not not costing the government
any to the state of New Hampshire any to
pass this and it it was just eliminates
you uh represent General ery uh thank
you Mr chair uh the only question I have
on this is regarding the cost of the
individual businesses to modify their uh
computer systems most restaurants have
computer systems now uh to to do this
and and I I I'm not sure if the point of
sale system has it built in where they
can ignore the tax that's already built
into their system uh if we give a little
clarification of that because that
question may come up if this goes to the
floor so we should be prepared to answer
it uh anyone in the room have any
information about
that if I could ask Mr
chair uh yes you may you may come up and
yourself uh thank you chair and other
members of the committee my name is
Brian Clark I'm general counsel for the
Bureau of elderly and Adult Services I
have with me maren Brown nutrition
consultant to the Bureau of elderly and
Adult
Services uh could you repeat the
question
please yeah thank you yeah the question
is what is the cost to the businesses to
implement a program that would
differentiate between the voucher system
uh customer and the regular
customer um that's going to be agency
dependent so right now we have just two
agencies out of our 10 contracted
agencies with our Bureau that are
providing this particular um the Meals
on Wheels
service um Hillsboro County did um
receive a grant to purchase the um EBT
software the debit card software that
they use um so they had support around
that getting their program off the
ground the actual cost I'm not sure but
they could report out on that Tri count
cap up in Coos County is the other
agency that's was in the pilot of this
program um they have not fronted up any
additional cost what they're doing is
they're using software that pre-exists
and they are using a paper voucher
system
so they're a really good representative
of what New Hampshire might see um a
larger um program that has uh more
ability to pursue grants and get funding
in a different way and could
pursue what you're talking about which
could initially cost them more money but
TR counted cap is an example of how at
least half of our programs would
probably go which is to utilize systems
already in place to make it work with
minimal cost follow
that actually wasn't responsive the
question is the cost to the provider to
restaurant so they already have to
differentiate between every restaurant
participating provides meals um to RVP
participants and then also are
for-profit businesses so they already
have to differentiate between this meal
was provided and it meets these
standards that the older Americans act
sets out so they should already have a
system in
place and hopefully this will answer
your question um my understanding to
date with both um Hillsboro County and
with Tri County cap there has been no
additional cost burden to the restaurant
to get the program rolling The dietitian
that's required to set up a menu built
into their existing menu is taken on by
the nonprofit agency contracted with us
um and the whether they do an EBT or a
paper voucher again that cost is
absorbed by the
agency not by the
restaurant thank you for that answer
appreciate it uh representative fellows
followed by representative Ames
so the way I heard the question and and
if I heard the question wrong then I
have this question I I think the issue
is is for the
restaurant they're programmed so that
everything that they sell the the room
the meals tax is applied automatically
to any sale that they
make so this
proposal if we were to adopt this they
would somehow have to not automatically
apply the room and meals tax to the
these particular meals
and how would they go about doing
that is there any piece that you want to
answer okay all right all right so
hopefully this may help when it comes to
there so this bill is only asking for
meals specifically provided under the
restaurant Voucher Program those meals
for anyone who this has not been
clarified for you um I allow me to do
that each meal includes a protein a
starch a vegetable a fruit water coffee
or tea so if you or I would to walk in
and we're part of the restaurant voucher
program and we go to a a participating
restaurant if we order the predetermined
menu that's been approved it would cost
us nothing other than a donation if we
did it and the tip but if you and I
chose to add something an appetizer a
dessert um a mosa that would not be
covered so there's an additional receipt
that would be be created like any other
restaurant and that would be covered um
that would be meal taxed but not the RVP
core meal I don't excuse me I don't
think that was your question was or so
it it was not my question but I'm glad
that you told us that because what I'm
hearing now is if somebody goes in with
a any a regular customer with without of
a
voucher goes in and they they buy a meal
it you know the they buy food that cost
you know
$10 and when the waitress goes to print
the bill for them
automatically
85% is added to the bill but this bill
asks that for those meals that that tax
of
82% not be
added and now I hear that people maybe
buying the dessert or drink on top of
that so their bill would have to
um automatically put the tax on the
dessert and the drink but not the meal
which makes it more complicated so my
question to the attorney is
how much of a burden is that going to be
for the restaurants to program
their whatever prints their bills so
that they can exclude things
okay so they already need to be able to
generate a receipt that a meal was
provided under the restaurant voucher
program and they certify that it meets
our standards our dietary standards our
dietary requirements so they already
have a system in place to generate
receipts for RVP and receipts for their
for-profit
business
so can I just say that having worked in
restaurants that all they're going to
that for that all they're going to do is
they're going to have a special instead
of saying hamburger it's going to
say um you know whatever this program is
voucher
so that that identifies that that that
they served that meal that does not
address the question we have about the
room and meals tax okay hopefully this
will continue to help as we we pair it
down um both of the all of the
restaurants that are currently
participating in this program in order
to be approved by our Bureau to be to
participate they have had to work with
the contracted agency's dietitian who
know who knows the standards of this
program and once that's created they
have a separate menu it's sort of like a
restaurant having um an early bird menu
and having a regular menu so it's built
into what the Food Service establishment
already does but instead of an early
bird menu they have an RVP menu so
there's no additional um cost or
anything like that as far as the
training component of it does that is
offered by all of our agencies for any
food service establishment that chooses
to join this program that they will
offer the training to the staff in any
way shape or form that they feel their
staff needs or what the agency has
identified of the restaurants that are
currently participating none of them
have reported an additional
cost in taking on this program
representative
amam yeah I I think we're making a
mountain out of a mo mhill here
um is it true that uh um one of the
reasons for this bill is that
currently vouchered
meals
are paid for by the senior center whe
The Entity that uh contract with and
then the tax that we're talking about
here is that t t uh paid by the senior
center to the government currently that
is also being paid by the nonprofit
uh subcontractor with our Bureau yes all
of it is by if that's true clearly the
restaurants are differentiating between
the the voucher meal and the other meals
right exactly okay um and the other
question or it's really rhetorical um
isn't it true that this is an entirely
voluntary program from the perspective
of the restaurants they can choose or
not Cho choose to do this and if uh it's
a nuisance to do it well they've decided
that's a cost that they they want to
Bear is that correct absolutely even the
contracts are written that if e either
party wants to back out because of
examples that you stated they have a a a
very very short reasonable window
whether it's on the part of the
nonprofit agency or the Food Service
establishment either one can say this
isn't working for me and yes it is I I
know I noed don't if this is being
recorded but yes each Food Service
establishment it's absolutely voluntary
and as of right now we have 1 2 3 we
have three restaurants with they're in
conversations with two others of those
two they approach the agency they heard
about this they are very Community
committed restaurants they believe in
providing a community support and they
saw this as a means to do it so they
actually approach the
agencies representative
Southworth uh thank you so just to
rephrase it I think I know where we got
off a little bit so the 8 and a 12% tax
on your meals never was paid by the
restaurant anyway no the our nonprofit
agency work for them it was just being
paid by you that makes it much clearer
you representative PL two points one uh
restaurants I think are approaching you
because they get business out of it that
they otherwise wouldn't get it increases
their traffic is that
correct that's a good way to frame it um
representative PL they potentially get
more traffic they don't necessarily make
more money because it's a fixed rate for
that same meal if you would see it on
their menu maybe be tweaked a little bit
because it has to meet our nutrition
standards but that same meal they could
be charging 1516 $18 for but they're
willing to take that reduction in what
we give them because they're Community
oriented Food Service establishments
follow up follow just full
disclosure I have the one of those cards
uh but when I send in half of us in the
room uh at the side of the table might
qualify uh but but uh when I do send in
money did send money into the state I
sent the whole thing not just the four
bucks I I sent the full cost of the meal
and then some so so uh but I I so SP so
much time in the legislature it got
cancelled on me so I had to have it
renewed and let's see if it gets
renewed thank you very much in full
fellows we received a um letter of
support from Tri County and it's dated
January 5th and it says that they're
working on setting something up but they
hadn't done it yet so can in you're
saying that there that it is in place
now
no they're still in process do you want
the brief history on how why it was
written like that do you need that today
but I would it is in process but I would
like to know what the um do you know the
restaurants that they're talking to do
do the current restaurant that they're
in conversation with is the full send
Bar and Grill and that's in Pittsburgh
which will um for those of you who know
our state and its geography um
Pittsburgh is almost about as far north
as we can possibly get in one of our
most rural cities or towns can you say
repeat that Pittsburg p i t no not
Pittsburgh the name of the restaurant
sure full send full send yeah full send
Bar and Grill yeah I had to have them
repeat it for me several times too it's
an unusual name the other potential
restaurant this is one that they had in
place and much like what has already
been discussed it didn't work for them
they changed ownership so they needed to
pull out and now they're back in
conversations with Tri County but
nothing none of these across my desk for
approval so they're all still in talking
phase but the other potential restaurant
to come back on board is the Wilderness
restaurant in
colbrook
thanks
questions you have another question M no
you all right um we'll take a a quick
straw poll in this one how many people
uh at this point this is a non-binding
strum yeah oh sure yeah so I get the
impression that the V the um the debit
cards already have the um tax in
them so I why do you say no explain the
debit card is just to show that you
remember and they took it take a swipe
of that so they can prove to the state
it was a Meals on Wheels program but uh
it it right now they do have the tax
included but this bill would change that
so it would not but but it doesn't cost
the state any because they turn around
and build the state a dollar less right
so my
whole so the whole question about the
restaurants billing the reasons the
vouchers work now is because the voucher
costs whatever the price of the meal is
the it covers plus the tax so if it's a
$15 maybe it's I don't know $15 meal 13
$13 meal and then that includes
tax
correct so that that was what we were
trying to get at so B 12 so tax wouldn't
differentiate well it's up to you you
can certainly say something
else
all right well let's then let's see
where people are on this again it's
non-binding uh how many people are for
OTP on the
1191 so one two three four five six 78
remaining
I'm not gonna I don't want to hold it up
I'm not I'm not going to keep it off the
consent calendar I just have concerns
about the fact that that there's no
income criteria for people to get this
voucher and I
also you know I I don't know the rest I
I don't know for sure that the
restaurants
understand the tax part but you know
it's not it's not that big a deal to me
up those who didn't raise their hands do
they want to say anything else about
this
okay Mr chairman yeah just a comment to
my fellow representative here I don't
think we should worry about the income
uh level of individuals because when
they come to a Meals on Wheels program
somewhere nobody says to them oh you
can't come in and eat because you earn
too much money even though you're over
65 or 60 or whatever it is like we do on
wilmet people come in we don't say
anything about their income level they
just come in to have a meal they donate
a two or $3 whatever they can afford and
out they go I I just don't like the idea
of putting an income
ery correct me if I'm wrong but it's my
understanding that the income level or
the status of the individual is
determined when they apply for the uh
the card of the or to enter the program
um other than that you'd be giving out
money to every person over the age of
65 so can sure um so I'm I'm familiar
with um the meals that are provided in
the senior centers now under this
program that does the funding and the
way it works cuz I've I've gone there
and um you you go
in you you go to a desk and they tell
you you know you check in and they have
a sign that
says contributions they have a jar for
contributions and there might be a
little sign that says recommended
contribution
$3 and but they they don't they're not
going to make you you're not required to
make a a contribution so there really
there's no income check on it and that's
part of the federal requirement for this
program
uh representative PL can we ask you
you've you've applied and received it
was there an income check there was not
it's open to anybody uh but uh th those
of us who uh have a shekele or two I'm
not rich but a shekele or two I pay the
entire
Freight
okay all
comments all right seeing we'll close
1191 we'll now open the work session on
HB
1254 relative to optional local public
occupancies rosone Ames I believe
representative Buco has a an amendment
on which we should test have before us
before we discuss this and
representative buo is here the
amendment's been handed out to everybody
okay it's just a very short little half
half paragraph and um so I would
recommend that we hear from uh
representative
buo this if this amendment needs to be
co-sponsored by somebody sitting on the
that okay why don't we take um a minute
ourselves
all right is uh representative uh bov
uh so this this amendment
just I'm trying I'm trying to answer
some some of the questions that came up
during the the uh public hearing last
week and so there was no dollar amount
in the bill and so we um drafted this
amendment to put the $2 per uh $2 per
day per
day
and $2 per occupancy per 24hour
period shall not exceed $2 for the 24
hour
period
um if the occupancy is exceeds $40 then
the occupancy fee is not
collected and um the length of time is
not to exceed 184 days so that it's not
permanent
questions any questions yes
representative PL well this certainly
improves it because because there's a
dollar amount place but uh you just the
bill just says
hotels and uh there's lots of uh a bnbs
and other types like that uh What uh
that would that apply to these rentals
as well I have I have the actual
definitions from statute can I pass this
out
it's I think that occupancy definition
will be important because this could
also affect um just normal landlord
rentals that you know 3 months four
months um well this is the this is the
state statute so well we'll take we'll
look
no those there's two different ones
they
yes oh oh sorry I made him I shouldn't
have done that but I supposed to cross
like
that okay so you are giving us the
definition of Hotel um hotel is
mentioned in the bill
itself yes in line
six okay you who's asking me that you in
in line number six the legislative body
uh five and
six um the legislative body may may vote
each legislative body may vote this is a
enabling legislation for the town and it
has to be voted on by the by the
legislative body of the
voters and uh each occupancy is defined
as
7883 XI that's that's the occup the O
definition for
occupancy and of each Hotel under the
7883 uh VII
that's that's on the first page under
under the chapter um 78a tax on meals
and rooms that I just passed
out well I guess I think it's
highlighted isn't it it is I guess my
concern would be the last word of the
first page and apartments um so
effectively the word hotel is being used
for virtually every single type of um
housing so that means landlords uh with
apartments that maybe they have someone
who you know it's month to month they go
four months six months and now they're
in that category um of it seems like
this could get a
little confusing in my mind uh
representative leapley followed by
represent
Bolton I just have um a comment and a
question so my first comment would be
so is this
better this is the current law So
currently this appears to be
working so landlords currently aren't
charging uh meals and rooms tax to
people they're renting out for a year
lease um my question would be
can given that this is the state law can
a town let's say the town has you know a
rooming situation where you know they
put certain a certain population they
wouldn't want to tax let's say could the
could the town clarify that when they
tax when they I'm sorry when they this
is just enabling so I'm assuming the
town would write something
saying the these people must charge $2 a
room in these situations so could the
town make it more clear where the $2 is
being charged or does the the town
just go based on the state law sorry if
that wasn't clear so I I believe that
they probably could the whole the the
point of this is point of this was that
the legislative body actually has votes
on whether to have this or not or
whether to resend it or not or how much
to how much to spend how much to uh
charge and
also how how how long that you know
that's why the the 184 days is in there
because if if it's permanent residents
are not being charged this followup
follow so if if I understand
correctly this is enabling legislation
and the town would be enabled to set
something up maybe they want to charge
less than
$2 uh maybe they want to focus on a
certain type of like let's say what we
would call hotels only the town could
make that clear in their statute yes
clarifying represent Bolton thank you Mr
chair so um to expand on your
observation that it also includes um
what was it College camps Barracks but
also dormatory
and you know we have a university in the
town of Plymouth and I'm quite certain
that they would not allow us to charge
$2 you know per per day
um but it would be certainly nice if
that were the case but you know I think
that's the problem with uh you know the
the
legislation yeah and um I you know full
disclosure I am a landlord I know
there's a lot of lot of people who are
landlords my concern would be the $2
doesn't sell like much but if somebody
is in for 6 months that's um 180 time2
$360 rents are high enough it could
encourage landlords to increase rents to
cover that cost um over here I saw hands
representative
Olie thank you representative for taking
uh questions I appreciate it um you've
talked about the
details putting a fiscal note in here or
a dollar value to whatever the fee is
but the question goes back to why is it
good State policy to allow a checker
board of different taxation across the
state different localities why is that
good consistent tax policy when it
violates most of
the uh form if you will for
taxation well represent of the the
expenses that are incurred by
industry they're they're they're the
different in every town too that that's
what happened that's what's happening
here when we have 3,000 hotel
rooms
and
um I'm sorry i u
that well so the the the expenses are
are check aboard
also so we we we have a we have a town
that has a big tourist tourism industry
and the population swells from 10,000 to
30,000 on weekends and in the
summertime and and
so what the the selectman came to us and
said can we do something to relieve the
the property tax
because the The increased expenses of
especially for First Responders and uh
emergency and
police um those those expenses are are
much higher than and and they're falling
follow perhaps you didn't quite
understand what I'm saying
you've got a patchwork of Taxation that
is different and the the the valuation
of a meals and rooms tax at uh 8 and a
half% is the same across the state every
place that you go to this would be $2
here but the next town over doesn't have
$2 right and the next town over has $2
and three Towns over has $2 but it's not
the same this would create
um a patchwork of
variation to be administered in some
addition let's take Lon for example Lon
is a Small Town Loon is a small is a
large town on weekends
season and yet they're going to get
there 30 what is it 30% goes to the town
something like that they're going to get
their percentage of the 8 and a half%
from the increase of each one of that uh
each person that's there who goes in and
buys a meal at one of the nice
restaurants or one of the little stores
down there or even the Dunkin Donuts
right off the highway I
just
so the question goes back
to why is creating that Patchwork
beneficial to the state and to its uh
marketing
campaign
well I don't know uh it's it's it it's
it's not to the state the benefit is
going to the municipalities
because they they because they haven't
to the benefit will go to the state
through the meals and rooms
revenues because because the the the
towns that have increased tourism bring
that draw that
in
and so okay representative ORS I'm not I
don't think I'm answering you correctly
but thank you Mr chair uh I like the
idea of relieving would you believe I I
like this idea of relieving the burden
on the local communities especially
these small communities that become huge
communities at certain times of the year
like Penn State College and Pennsyvania
on a game day weekend becomes the third
largest city in Pennsylvania so I
understand what you're trying to do I
don't think you're here you're there yet
and I'm all for Shifting the burden to
the tourists that are coming up here and
enjoying what we have to offer and
relieving the burden on the taxpayers I
just think this needs more work needs to
be thought out better thank you
representative
fellow um I I
recall a bill like this being in a
municipal and County committee last year
are do you
know did you have this bill before
before or do you know about this bill
before I I did not have this bill before
but I but I did see I did see some of
those that I used in
research
um and and took some took some of the
language
so if we if we did pass this bill would
it go to Municipal and County my
recollection is that they didn't like it
at
all I'm not sure on that well is it you
know um if it needs work I I we we don't
you know we agree you
can um amend it as you as you need to in
the committee
and so I guess that would mean at least
um interim study if it needs more
time I I agree with representative ores
that in general what you're trying to do
makes sense um and the question is um
how best to do it I think um represent
leap Lee followed by representative
PL thank you Mr chair thank you for
um I think the discussion's been very
thought-provoking so far and um the
thought that comes to mind is that it
sounds like what people are saying is we
acknowledge that towns have different
needs and and they have different you
know population flows throughout the
season because we're such a beautiful
state um it sounds like what we would
prefer is to
increase the tax on meals and rooms and
I know one of the other bills we're
considering um at some point is
uh Bill to decrease the tax on meals and
rooms which would be you know a non
Patchwork solution so my question to you
is if
the the people who came to you with a
problem saying hey you know people would
really love to live in our town um but
it's becoming increasingly hard because
we are shouldering the burden of all of
these tourists that come in and they're
not paying their fair share we're paying
for all of the police emergency whatever
is required whatever city services are
needed and the you know everyday folks
uh nurses police men can't afford to
live in our town anymore we need a
solution to this problem do you um so it
seems like the obviously we want to find
the best solution to that problem would
a solution to that problem be to raise
the tax on meals and rooms is it that
your town is not getting enough money
back um on that tax so I guess my
question is do you feel like that would
be a solution to the
problem well the the town is not getting
is already not getting it what it needs
through meals and rooms that's what Pro
that's what provoked you know uh
in thank you represent
PL I had a variant on that question um
right now I I think the percent back to
towns uh cities and towns out of the
rooms of meals tax I I'm remembering 40%
I might be wrong 30 okay it was higher
when the rooms and meals tax was
initially imposed if the legislature in
a future budget did increase that
percentage would that help rather than
having a separate two doll tax it would
it would certainly help if if the
municipalities got got um a
proportionate share proportionate to
their expenses right now they're not
getting that they're getting it based on
population
well let me just correct something I
believe uh the de facto rate that was
being sent back was
22% um we raised it from 22 to 30 no
that's what I mean it was so it it's
we've actually deao it was 22 we we set
set it I think it was last year uh to
30% so so that percentage actually is
higher than than it has been um so I
mean obviously there's still an issue
but but the rate has I just want to
correct that that the rate has uh
increased um I let me just follow up
with representative spillsbury yeah I I
think the committee should uh return to
a work session where we can discuss and
debate amongst ourselves are we ready to
do that possibly did anyone else have
questions for the
representative okay thank you thank
you
so okay representative Ames on that note
yeah yeah I I think there's a variety of
problems with the bill is drafted maybe
they could be uh addressed and
improved um for example I think that
when you get to
184 days in this amendment you know
isn't that isn't that
residence the whole point of the meals
and rooms is to distinguish between uh
visitors and uh and doile and Most
states once you're in a place for 180
days or more you're literally a doile of
that
location so there are other
imperfections I think what I can
Envision and it's been alluded to by
representative
leapley
is I get it we currently take 30% could
be 22 could be 40 it was originally
40 and we pull we pull all meals and
rooms and we distribute pra across the
state according to population that works
out very well for my constituency
because we have virtually
no um meals and rooms capacity Sullivan
County has the least pull in terms of
generating meals and rooms so I don't
want to give up the 30% but I I think
that the argument being made
by Advocates from Portsmouth and Conway
and Plymouth and so on is is very strong
so the question is how do you do it you
know if if if you
recognize the demands on their safety
services and and roadways
Etc I would think and and I think this
is a 2025 project not a 2024
Resurrection uh we've got a variety of
bills that suggest reducing the meals
and rooms tax and there's certainly a
sentiment for that amongst some
Representatives why not take these
things and merge them together with the
concept that uh the meals and rooms tax
comes down uh by one or one and a half%
say to seven or seven and a half but the
municipality is allowed to search charge
it by one or one and a half percent con
continue to distribute this 30% of the
state's
pool
pra but allow for that other portion to
go directed to where the service demand
is most under stress there are many
states that do this what it would
exactly look like in the Drafting and
and so on you know if there's interest
in the committee I'd certainly be
willing to work towards a bill of that
sort in
2025 but but coming up with a completely
new fee that's administered and
collected entirely
locally doing it in the way this bill
suggests I don't feel that I'm prepared
to vote for that this year next year
we've got a a budget cycle year and uh
maybe there's a better
approach that's a very interesting
approach uh definitely could um have
some Merit representative um Rochford
yes thank you Mr chairman and I
my colleague down at the end of the
table is far more eloquent than I am and
uh so I'm glad that he was able to um
summarize that but but I I I I I can
empathize with Conway and Portsmith and
some of those other towns in that the
time that I come through is very similar
we have a population of 5800 but on any
given day could be 25,000 because we're
we're a draw and we're we're
experiencing a lot of the same things
that uh that we heard here but and and I
think representative leapley summarized
it as well and and and um of course what
we just heard I think it's not
necessarily A I think I think we need as
a committee to get a little more
creative with the policy rather than
just tax more uh because it is more
nuanced it is more there is more to uh
the issue than just collecting more um
you know my colleague across the room
brought up uh Lincoln and and you can't
get through Lincoln and and and on a on
a average day this time of year because
it's so crowded but they do they
generate a huge amount of revenue for
the state and it's their police that's
taxed their fire that's taxed um they
give they send the money out of town and
they're only getting a small per portion
of that so again I think representative
spillsbury had it right and I would be
happy to work on that with him and it's
not so much I think I think the issue is
valid but I think
we have to take on the issue and get
more a nuanced policy to most
adequately address the issue thank you
representative
Ames uh I guess several things one is um
I think what we've just been talking
about and hearing suggestions on is
beyond the scope of this bill um you're
getting into and I think uh
representative spillsbury said as much
this is an FY 25 a next year project for
something like that um it is also the
case that uh that kind of bill has been
presented in the past more than once
while I've been in this seat and it's
gone nowhere I think there we we would
hear from Dr about uh identifying the
source of the money that comes into the
state it's often paid by a central
collecting point so it may not it may be
some small town where the address is
that's sending in the revenue and in
fact Conway wouldn't uh uh be shown as
the source on McDonald's uh remittances
for example um so there are
complications that's all I'm saying I
don't think we need to get into that
discussion um I think we have in front
of our us a bill that calls for uh
enabling localities to Institute attacks
on hotels and on occupancies in hotels
those are the two uh words of art um
that are defined somewhere else but we
defined for a different purpose to
representative lepley's question I
actually think that this would have to
be amended to enable the municipalities
to fine-tune that language to Target on
uh a subset of the hotel category um but
that could be done and um I I would be
willing to work on an amendment like
this I'm not one of the original
proponents of this I think find it an
interesting proposal and I'd like to
have the best version of that in front
of us um but I'm willing to work on it
only if there's sentiment that that will
go somewhere in this committee so I'll
be interested in a in a STW poll on that
I'd say the work that needs to be done
is to enable
municipalities to adopt a version of
this authorization that's less than the
whole that's described here so they can
pick what they want and one other
comment is that the 180 days um that's
in the definition I think um is um is a
distinction between short-term rentals
that are the subject of this tax today
of the rooms and meals tax and those
that are in a different C category that
are not subject to it that's all it is
and uh and again in terms of fine-tuning
maybe that should be out of the picture
in amendment that we would do but um it
that that has a very
solid arig in the 180 days and it's an
attempt to avoid taxing long-term rental
um you know and that's that's the time
period that was chosen so that's my
comment I'd be interested in a short in
a uh straw pole and uh and see where
we're at and uh if we're headed for a
dead end well we're headed for a dead
end you know
so thank you representative
shamber thank you Mr chairman uh I agree
with representative Ames the the the
towns and cities have come here with a
problem and they have
suggested approaches to this
problem and they're looking for for the
state to say okay this is very creative
or whatever and representative Ames has
haded added the I think the the part
that needs to be added to this bill to
uh I don't
see a reduction in the meals and rooms
or taking more money here or there uh
that's taken away from the what this
bill is about and it also affects our
public education trust system uh the
funds going into that so I think that
representative Ames has put forth a a
positive way to address the cities and
towns that need to have this thank
you represent
fellows so I think there certainly are
cases in in in many towns where tourists
cause the
the um municipality to have to expend
more
money there's not
always um this is not the tourists that
that um create the need for police
primarily I think it's mostly police
maybe you know Ambulance Service are not
necessarily the people who are in hotel
rooms because an example of this would
be in my town we we have a full-time
police officer during the summer and the
fall because of hikers coming into the
state and parking alongside of the road
and with the potential to block the road
when they they want to hike in the
mountains around my town and this has
been going on for years we don't have
very many hotels in we have some but not
very many so that that's one you know
the Nexus between the increase of cost
and the
um the idea that you can recover the
money from just hotel rooms the other
thing that I'd like to point out is for
every single hotel room that
exists that municipality is is
collecting more than $1,000 a year from
that room you know not not NE not the
bnbs but you know regular hotels on the
they're collecting it through the
property tax so they are getting
significant contribution from from those
um the people who use the the hotels and
the
airbnbs so I I think I'd rather not see
New Hampshire go down the road of of
having to tell tourists you know you
know we know the tourists w know that
they they always get the the tax on
their hotel bill whatever percent it is
but let's not go down the road of saying
and then there may be another tax on
your on your bill because my
recollection of the testimony I heard in
Municipal and county is that tourists
really hate to see that extra line of
tax they're they don't mind one line of
tax they expect that but they don't like
to see additional uh lines of taxes on
their hotel
builds well you raised an interesting
point about the the part where it's not
always the hotel um because a town like
Salem we while we do have a new hotel in
Tuscan Village the the number of
occupancies in Salem is very low however
Salem a town of population about
30,000 during the day every day the town
of Salem's population from what I've
read converg in up to 100,000 people
because we have so many shoppers so with
Salem it's retail and there's no we're
not going to collect much from hotels
but we still need a stronger police
presence we need uh I mean almost just
by chance I'm not driving through town
every day but it almost seems like one
out of every three days I see either an
emergency um an ambulance or a fir truck
responding to something so you know that
that would be my concern and in you know
to your point of it's not always
hotels Al although I recognize there is
a problem um in general um yes
representative spillsbury
yes representative shamberg I I'm not
sure I was grasping what you were saying
about the impact on local education
funding could you just clarify
that were we talking about the meals and
rooms tax I believe it was in the
context of uh the rate of the meals and
rooms and the concept of some of it
being shared to those communities that
have you know a lot of lodging visitors
I was concerned that if we're going to
share more of the meals and rooms it's
also going
to reduce our Revenue that we put into
the public education trust fund I don't
think any of other than car rentals none
of the meals and rooms Revenue goes into
representative PL I think representative
fellow's made an excellent point when
she mentioned property tax the fact that
the hotel exists in the first place
means that there's property tax on it so
there is revenue for the town and if
it's a if it's a robust Hotel uh busy I
would think that that would affect the
property value of it's taxed on up as
opposed to one that's got a barely
surviving that proper they could argue
with lower property tax so the town is
now anything
else okay seeing
nothing um I will close the uh work
um actually I'm going to reopen the work
session for a second
yes yes thank you for coming um I'm
reopening it uh primarily because I I
forgot to do a stop hole
um okay yeah did you want to say
something yes if I could
add I like what I heard with
what what dick Ames said here and the
representative fellows and anything that
shifts the birden into the tourist who
are if you will creating the need and
takes the burden off the locally local
property taxpayers and those that live
in these towns is something I am
for thank you um so let's see how best
to phrase this I guess um how many well
first we can start with how many people
um would like to see this OTP or otpd
with a type of um potential amendment
that representative Ames is suggesting
show off hands one two three four five
six
seven um how many
against
one
two myself three four five six seven
okay we're I think it needs work we're
we're missing
some how much time do how much time do
we have for for this bill I mean in
terms of days when does when does it
have to leave us uh all the bills in
Ways and Means um none of them are early
bills oh good so it doesn't uh I mean on
one hand we need to process through
bills if we know how we want to go with
them the other hand we do have time yeah
well
so um yes representative sod I just
wanted to point out that miss this all
uh uh the major tax burden in towns are
schools and their enrollments are
dropping so perhaps we should look to
well uh yes Le I just want to point out
that and I live in Manchester and our
enrollments have dropped a little bit um
but doesn't cost less to run the schools
right we we it hasn't dropped so much
that we're like closing schools and
firing people
so yes enrollments are going down across
the state but that doesn't translate I
think the the shorthand of per pupil
expense kind of um confuses us to think
oh it cost that amount to educate a kid
so you take one kid out you save
$122,000 it the math doesn't work that
way um and the money is not would not
come from school boards right it's
property taxes where that money is
coming from but obviously that is a huge
expense in our
state okay all right I'm going to close
uh the work session
okay I'm gonna open the uh public
session on not public I'm going to open
1515 relative to the meals and rooms
tax and let's
see
still trying to find it there it is
representative
PL this and uh other bills to try to
reduce tax this year I think it's the
wrong year I think that uh right now
we're running a surplus in uh in plan
over plan but it's last I looked was
around $100
million uh that that's great but it's
not huge in the impact of the overall
bium and so I would want to defer any
talk about reinstating first of all a uh
year representative spillsbury
exactly the point I was going to lead
with so I'll Echo that point I think
it's the wrong year to be considering
this um we can always be thinking about
it uh and without getting back into it
we could be thinking in terms of the
purpose of the last bill and
coordinating those two concepts for next
year I I would also just make one other
incidental comment and that
is I'm I'm not warm to section two of
this bill which picks a figure and
freezes it uh for the revenue sharing I
I think we should you know we we we
depend upon meals and
rooms and to the tune of 30% Revenue
sharing our communities depend upon
their share and I think that should
float we should evalue the rate next
year in the context of where our budget
Ames well I agree with my colleagues
um and um maybe I have a
different long-term goal than they but I
think it's absolutely right this is not
a bud budget year um we're coming off of
uh a couple of years of where we've uh
been maybe three years I'm not sure with
uh we've been uh blessed with a huge
infusion huge infusion of federal money
uh
unprecedented uh that was a result of
the pandemic and um that's going away
the picture is cloudy where we are
Revenue wise the big generator of taxes
has been the business profits tax and uh
the business Enterprise tax um and um
what where will they be a year from now
or two years from now um truth is
anybody who's honest about this uh
cannot really predict that because there
are too many variables uh the the
broader economy the local economy um are
are the terms of of the tax itself which
is switched over to a single sales
factor and that's just coming into view
I think uh although we have not been
briefed on that yet by Dr but that's a
big change in uh in the U way in which
the uh uh tax identifies the taxable
revenues um so um to
to take out of the revenue stream an
amount of money given all of that and
given the other truth that there we've
got pressing needs in a budget you go
through the process and you do what you
can do with the money you've got and uh
this past time around I think the budget
makers the people at the center of that
activity did a great job we all came
together around a budget but in the end
a budget is a
is doing what you can best do with what
you've got and um that's what we came to
we did what we could best do with what
was available to us in revenues nothing
extra nothing fat um just uh a good
budget with what we had but that doesn't
mean that we took care of all the needs
and I won't go through a list I'm sure
everybody could make their own list
publicly or privately on that I have
happen to be in the thick of the public
school funding issue as is
representative spillsbury we're both
sitting on a special committee to
address school funding and thinking hard
about uh you know how to how to deal
with that issue and maybe the outcome
for some of us on that subcommittee or
in the larger committee the education
committee will uh see no need to go
further with the state money than we do
now but Others May see an opportunity to
switch State money for
state for local property tax money um
and uh so net net taxes don't change but
uh it does use more State money um and
uh we need to keep that open in my
judgment so I hope I my plea is not to
go down that uh uh shrinking of the uh
tax revenues pathway at at certainly at
this juncture it's not a budget year I
think it's a bad time to do
that thank
you sure yes oh okay I'm use his light
from now on because I know it's very
hard yeah I'm sorry but he's he'll help
me um I agree with all the previous
speakers I think this would be a good
time to pause both reductions and
increases in taxes for this particular
year um I'm concerned I think the YDC
lawsuit is going to cost much more than
$100 million we're just beginning to see
results of that and we don't know what's
going to happen with the education
funding and those are two really big
things that could reduce our Surplus
very quickly um and then we've made so
many changes already and we haven't even
seen what's happened including now the
arpet type funds all going away so it
just seems like a sensible for this
committee a sensible time to
pause thank you
okay
anybody else all right seeing none um
actually we'll do a straw poll how about
that uh how many
people raise your hand if you are for
passing
hp55 wow okay not surprising based on
the comments all right uh let me just
note
are there is there's 14 of us here one
five okay we will close the public
1515 next up is HP 1422 relative the
rates of the business profits tax
business Enterprise tax communication
Services tax and uh rooms of meals tax
we'll open that uh work
session represent any other comments I
made the made on the last
bill okay thank you for the succinct
statement uh representive Southworth I
had a long list of comments and I will
stop all of them because I agree with
representative PL I think we really
already had this discussion
okay
um anybody else want to say anything on
hp1
okay seeing none we'll close the uh work
session on
H uh I think okay we can take a straw
poll on that how many people are for OTP
1422 okay seeing none we'll close that
session all right the last three bills
we have are all
um related to the
um business profits tax and um we will
um invite well I'll open the this
hearing for the um work session but um
Dr is here to help us with these I'll
open the um work session first on hp1
1531 and um I'm going to invite uh Dr up
uh at this time because I know I have a
question even though I may be the prime
bill morning U my name is Keen mang Wong
Texas police council with the new H dep
depart Revenue um I'm here to answer
questions thank you um I think the um
the first question is going to be um you
know when we look at these three 1533
seems fairly straightforward but uh
1531 um can you explain well first
explain what that what sort of
depreciable property does this pertain
to uh in general the depal property
would be those that are uh 20 years or
or less uh of the uh depreciable life um
there is a lot of overlap between this
property that's uh qualified in for 168k
deduction um so a uh like a
Machinery that could qualify for um this
bonus depreciation could potentially
also qualify for the um 179 deduction if
it was all
um that's
uh that's Federal Federal yeah and
that's Bill 15 uh 36 is going address
the first year um the first year
deduction so Mr
chairman yeah 1531 and 1536 are so
interrelated because in fact the IRS
allows an election to take one or the
other but not both maybe we should talk
about them uh together to group them for
the purposes of this discussion okay
that's uh Point well taken um I guess EX
yeah explain to us um um section
79 right 179 so Section 179 uh deduction
is a first year deduction similar to
um 168k uh when the business acquires uh
a property and place it into service in
that particular year um the business if
that asset qualifies the business would
be able to take a firste deduction to ex
as opposed to depreciating that property
over the life of the asset the business
has the ability to um claim that expense
as a deduction in the first year of
placing it into service so that 179
expense currently deduction currently is
uh a deduction that's allowed for New
Hampshire business profits tax purposes
uh it is currently limited to but the
aggregate amount of deduction is
currently limited to a million
80,000 uh no for for New Hampshire for
New Hampshire is um that's Federal
you're talking yeah that's the federal
number yeah
yeah yeah New Hampshire is uh currently
um 500,000 500,000 y currently is
$500,000 the uh HB 1536 intends to
increase that to a million dollar right
and and the federal is what you although
I think I heard the federal um I think
the federal was adjusted up to a million
160 for
2023 yes okay
um and let's just go I'll get you in a
minute representative PL let's just go
back to uh
section 168 again 168 um is for all
property 20 years or less and is it how
does that work is that first year only
so it is uh it is first year as well
it's a bonus depreciation and then and
uh it's in the during the year that
placed in
service um and for federal the amount
the allowed amount of um I guess the the
percentage that's allowed to take as a
deduction is decreased year over year um
with
uh starting with which year let me see I
don't have that right in front of me but
it does start um decreasing 20% year
over year and then it goes to zero in
2027 um and so that's the current law on
the federal side so on the federal side
bonus depreciation for Section 168
property goes away in whatever number
next yeah in 2027 when for assets
placing service after 2027 right um and
then uh the the HB
1531 is to and we currently do not um
allow the bonus depreciation deduction
for BPT purposes
1531 allows puts that into uh anex that
um deduction and allows that deduction
for BPT purposes and then
also does not does not adopt the uh the
the federal phase out and keeps it at
% um can you just explain then the
difference some of the property I think
you said some of the depreciable
property between section 168 and
179 could fall in the same category so
yeah does a business decide
which so when a when an when an asset
does does qualify for both 179 and
168k the priority would be on the
federal side the priority would be
taking the 79 deduction first and then
if there is additional um because the
179 deduction there are some limitations
in terms of the
calculation um and then when there are
more qualified assets than allowed us to
deduction then the taxpayer has the
option well the taxpayer would then take
the 168k for the remaining
um remaining basis of the asset that was
not
deducted uh and through 179 and take it
on the
168k all right representative PL thank
you I'm going to confirm before I make a
statement this uh well uh if we were to
pass both of these it could have a
short-term negative impact on Revenue
but uh overall it's Revenue neutral is
it not
because the future years they won't be
able to take the depreciation they
already took it right that is correct
yeah yes so my statement is I'm I look
much more kindly on the these than I do
did uh out andout tax rate reductions on
previous bills because it is revenue
neutral long term and it it's uh
friendly to business yeah it's more
Ames basically I I share that
perspective just uh uh just stated
perspective but on these uh these kinds
of changes but uh I do have uh I don't
really understand uh on 1531
why uh we would push the applicable
percentage for this Bon I think it's
called bonus
depreciation up to 100% And the federal
law law what what is it down to
[Music]
now 40% 20% you don't have it in front
of I don't have it in front of me but um
and then just to just to add a little
wrinkle stepped down to 60% as of
December 31st 23 okay you've got got
it's already gone through two step
decreases that congruent with what you
think yes it's it's already been going
down already um and then um I mean it
does not matter what I'm going to say
next is because of the the bill that was
just passed in on on the by the house
Federal US House us house um
the what's the name of it um something
about oh yeah
workers uh it also it actually U brings
it back up to 100% up to a certain year
I can't remember which year though but
then but then um for BPT purposes we are
not on a rolling Conformity with the
federal um right tax code so I I guess
as I said it doesn't really matter what
they're doing right now on the federal
tax code um because we are only
conforming to the December 3128 18 right
now TX code yeah so first point is that
I wouldn't make any bets on what the
Congress is going to do they still has
to pass the and uh after that um I think
um
that
uh even if this is going up to 100%
federally usually where we do uh which
would be in accord with that going up
usually we follow the federal government
government on on uh tax code and uh
decide whether or not to conform uh we
usually we don't go a go down a
different pathway with something totally
outside the bounds of that I there might
may be examples where we
do for the for the most part yes we
conform to the the code and then uh in
specific parts of our BPT statutes we
would have adjustments to to adjust uh
let's say the legislature decided to um
like like for the 179 deduction it was
at 500,000 for a good number of years so
to uh if we were simply to conform and
we have not conformed to bonus
depreciation to do that we do that
without the sentence in here which says
the applicable percentage shall mean
100% is that correct that is correct
yeah uh so I think that's a question for
us um I I don't know the consequences I
guess you don't either because of this
mishmash between different different
options that businesses have right but
somebody must be pushing for this and
and it must me make a difference for
somebody I don't know why this is in
front of us actually why there a felt
need with a uh a bonus depreciation
that's about to disappear at least
absence some congressional action that
may or may not happen represent
Pillsbury very similar comments so I can
be very brief I'm I'm not sure we should
be weighing in on this moving
Target yeah and uh yeah I I I think that
our it's not clear who's really for this
nobody came and testified on it I don't
I'm not sure what the impetus is I think
we're fine to leave our statute the way
yeah okay um yes representative shamber
thank you Mr chairman thank you Kean uh
uh two
questions on
depreciation does the company identify
which type of depreciation they will
take on
their on the forms that you that are
provided to you like straight line or
declining balance or double declining
and some of the years digits do do they
identify those things or do
they or do you figure it out when you
see what they're wanting to deduct um I
I to be honest I cannot fully uh answer
that question I know that uh right now
for federal depreciation is the modified
adjusted cost reduction basis so it's
the
makers uh format and then
um the double decline
in well it's just I'm not so much
worried about do they identify do they
tell the Dr no no no uh currently we
only look we would see how the assets
are depreciated either through the
federal forms that submitted or if that
information is not there and we need
more information um and if that
taxpayers being audited then uh the
Auditors would request for more detailed
depreciation schedule okay follow up on
follow up and the second question I have
the
the dates that are on here when they
will be placed in service uh like on
1531 on line 8 it mentions about being
placed in service after December 31st
2024 C can these
dates be
changed or or or do they affect what the
the um present bills that or the present
tax law does it clear up anything by
moving the dates out further um
especially since we have the single
sales Factor uh I think what
representative spillsbury has brought up
as maybe letting these work their way
out what we presently have before we
address something like this is that what
spury yes thank you for the question it
is I I think it's crucially important
Whenever there is any kind of um tax
change we need to like's say for this
one we need to understand when it starts
and and so specifically for these kinds
of um bills that talks about
depreciation we need to know U which
asset would be subject to the this this
depreciation allowance and um so having
that clearly stated here for assets uh
that's placed in service after December
3124 so it would only apply to assets
place and service after that date and
not let's say if the bill was to pass at
a certain time and then you know okay
when it would apply so that I think it's
important to have that representative PL
thank you Mr chair all right um right
now we don't allow the 168 k at all
that's correct for BPT purposes if we
were to strike the line on line eight
the applicable percentages provided in
section 168 k6 shall mean 100% then we
would allow the
168 K uh adjustment but we would be
conforming with the federal law is that
correct with the phase out uh including
any phase out or reinstatement or
whatever happens the reinstatement is
after the December 31
2018 so we are following we're
conforming to the Internal Revenue code
as of December 31 2018 which does not
have the
reinstatement okay but if the Federal
Law changes we'd follow it no the
Federal Law changes now would not be the
Internal Revenue code as of December 31
2018 we would have to have another bill
we we are currently following as he said
the 2018 version so no matter how it
changes we're still following 2018 I
have okay so I'd be pushing for that
passing this but getting rid of the 100%
yes this is just to clarify a couple of
things make sure I understand for all
practical purposes when we have a
20year service life cut
off I think it's generally the case that
really only real
estate real property uh has a service
life longer than 20 years virtually any
kind of Capital Equipment I can think of
uh it's allowed uh more rapidly at least
roughly is is that a working distinction
that's that's mostly correct because
real estate is 37 and a half right and
then the second um so it's it's my
understanding uh generally that it's
always the year in which an asset is
placed in service yes that's correct uh
that that defines what the options are
and elections according to the Internal
Revenue code are taken in that tax year
and you know if you go for one for
straight line versus macrs and so on you
make that election I think you're stuck
with it for the life of the asset aren't
you you you're not just allowed to
freely change between uh um
methods U you know not without
justification there might be an
exception what to what I'm saying but I
believe it is generally correct that
you're you make your election and you
stick with it as far as I've seen I I
don't I've not seen um taxpayers
flipping uh from one um depreciation
method to another depreciation method
for any particular um property asset
property
um during the life of that property yeah
uh if I jump hold on just a correction
or not a correction but a question you
said 37 A2 years for real estate isn't
it 27 A2 for residential unless you're
talking about commercial
37 there are several categories there's
there's different categories but
residential real estate I believe is 27
and a half uh I I may not be too
familiar with
residential um yes so my point was just
that uh businesses can flip their
depreciation in my understanding my
training what I've seen uh but it's rare
and they got to justify it they just
can't do it and say you know well I felt
good that day so MH yeah there's got to
be a good reason and they can't skew
their balance sheet Etc there there's it
gets complicated and and they might I I
believe in certain situations they might
need to get approval from the IRS I
suppose yeah most likely um so the the
um I guess one question I would have is
there's
no limit let's say we are following the
federal law and it's at 100%
um There's No Limit such as in in um
Section 179 where the limit is 1 Point
whatever 06
million this section 168 or section 168
doesn't put any limit does it that's
correct there's no limit on the 168k so
I guess that's um uh that that's my
concern I didn't necessarily realize
that when I put this bill in so the No
Limit is is a concern um representative
leapley thank you um
that might answer one of my questions I
have two questions so one why is it
bonus um and two am I right in
understanding the
federal
um statute ends in
2027 if we pass this would it because
we're not paralleling the federal right
it I don't see that this would also
expire in 2027 those are my two
questions um
I can't I can't answer the the
nomenclature of bonus okay maybe it's
because um it's an accelerated
depreciation okay um that makes sense
and then uh if we were to uh adopt this
bill but without the language of the
100% um it will follow the phase out of
the of the federal uh law right now
right um which is which would be 0% if
the ass that was placed in service after
27 okay it be 0% wait a minute is that
true because you just said we're still
on
2018 that's correct so the phase out is
in the 2018 oh it is okay yeah all right
thank you so just to wrap it up I would
agree with what representative
spillsbury said is that this is maybe
unnecessary and adds a layer of
complication to the tax code that is of
yes representative ORS thank you so if
we were to go to a three-year tax on
equipment over a million
dollars anything but real estate so uh
not a three-year I'm sorry a three-year
depreciation would that negatively
impact the state's Revenue that you know
of I mean if you to use your crystal
ball so any equipment over a million
dollars can depreciate over threee
period versus whatever and just
eliminate like a flat depreciation of
three years I believe if everything
Remains the Same it was it would be also
another timing issue because a timing um
concern because on the federal side the
uh the the the taxpayer is able to is
only able to claim the depreciation over
that life of the the asset versus in New
Hampshire were claiming over three years
and then um as after the three years the
the New Hampshire taxpayer would not be
able to claim the depreciation on that
because they've already fully claimed
the
depreciation um so it's all uh front
loaded the depreciation on that asset is
the deduction is front loaded for the
first three years and then for the
remaining years there won't be a so it's
a timing thing but do you think that
would
negatively uh impact the state's Revenue
stream if we did something like that if
everything in other words to simplify it
yes if everything Remains the Same the
front loading of the depreciation means
you're increasing the deduction so
you're reducing your taxable income um
so you're reducing your BPT revenue for
those first three years yeah Y and then
it then you get it back in the ladder
it'll be a timing yeah yeah anything to
simplify it I think would be great thank
you representative fellas did you still
have a question um yes and it's not a
I'm just trying to educate myself so
you've been talking about about 170 I I
understand
168k what is is 179 is that a federal
yes it's a federal code and because you
made a statement that 179 is like 168k
and they're both Federal codes yes
they're both Federal codes what does 179
do so 179 is a first year deduction when
the uh asset is placed into service in
year one the the taxpayer would have the
option to claim the cost of that asset
as a deduction as opposed to claiming it
as a depreciation over the life of the
asset a deduction so is that just just
so I can follow so that's the same as
depreciating it 100% the first year
similar yes okay so they sound like the
same thing yes similar except that
except that
168 has has down and down so
179 that doesn't go down that's just it
doesn't go down but there there are uh
limitations on special not not all
assets uh not all assets similar to the
168k not all assets but however there is
um you cannot claim the uh 179 deduction
uh in excess of the taxable income I
believe it's taxable income so you can't
go into an nool you won't they won't
allow you to go into an nool position uh
when you're claiming at 179 for 68 you
can there's no limit to the 168 so
there's no limit yeah so you could
actually have a a loss and then apply
that loss to Future years right okay
thank you that's that's helpful yes
followup I'm sorry and you're not
allowed to take both R you is it one or
the
other uh if that is correct so but on a
particular asset you might be able to
claim both but not on the same basis so
if the the basis of let's say $100,000
of the basis of the asset um let's say
um maybe $80,000 is claimed under1 179
and then you still have 20,000 remaining
bases which you might be able to claim
on the 168k oh my God can can I take the
okay anyone else yes represent flood I
remember Mr Wong that during the uh
hearing on this bill public hearing both
you and I struggled over
macrs it's modified accelerated cost
recovery system
um I I'm inclined to um myself probably
just itl this
because um as I said when I put it in I
didn't realize there was no limit and um
and I think
complicating this right now with limits
uh probably isn't the way to go um
so um quick STW on that uh yeah I
noticed um before you do the straw I
just like to agree with you Mr chairman
since I
was the co-sponsor one of the
co-sponsors from the other side of the
aisle that uh some of this information I
did not understand when we had it
written up and
uh I I thought we were looking at it
would stimulate investment it would it's
a uh it's a job hiring it's it's more
stable was my thought at the time I
think I think well that to that point I
think it still can stimulate business
activity but the question is how much
does it affect right business Revenue
especially where you can end up with an
no um so
um that that's a concern whereas uh
actually HB
1536 you cannot end up with with a loss
and there is a limit so um it it it may
be that
you may wish to uh have co-sponsor that
one instead but we'll see where your
thoughts
let's um let's take a straw Paul I think
we know the answer but how many people
you okay I'm going to close the um and
Mr Wong if you don't mind staying up
there because we're going to need you
again um I'm going to close the U work
session on HB
1531 we'll now open the work session HB
1533 this is relative to allowing
um relative the Safe Harbor compensation
amount under the business profits
tax and do I have comments or questions
on this representative fellows so I I
just need to understand what this is so
let me tell you what I think it is and
you can tell me if I am on track or not
um so if you if you're a small business
you can claim a salary for
yourself but there's a limit on how high
that salary can go without
documentation uh yes that's
correct right so so the limit right now
is
75,000 and um I guess I'll ask you a
1533 the last time that was um updated
to the 75,000 I believe I'm not finding
it now but I think it was around 2011 or
2011 and so it has been uh 13 years uh
at 75,000 so the thought here was that
uh with inflation this should be raised
I like this bill um one of the things I
did is I noticed that it says it doesn't
it it it can go up every year um based
on the Consumer Price Index but it's
not um doesn't go up based on a single
year change in the Consumer Price Index
it's averaged over two years and uh I'm
from familar with using the cons
Consumer Price Index as a way to to keep
up with cost in when it comes to
adequacy a education and in that bill um
the when I worked on it and put it
together the governor changed it but it
was a three-year average and it's good
to have that average because it can be
very spiky in terms of the Consumer
Price Index being high one year and then
low another year year so even evening
this out is a good idea thank you
representative
Ames I I support this bill um I just
wanted to point out that uh in case uh
some aren't aware of it it underlying
this
uh this uh
deduction that's available um is a uh a
reasonable compensation Rule and
basically this is carving out a safe
harbor so that if you're below the
amount that that's going to be specified
that is currently specified basically Dr
and its Auditors aren't going to be able
to challenge you or um mostly will not
because they've got too high too steep a
hill to climb to defeat uh a claim for
uh of compensation that's under that
limit um but once you're above that the
rule is there it's reasonable
compensation and uh if somebody claims a
million dollars for the value of his or
her Services during the past year and it
just doesn't correlate with anything I
suspect the Dr will be uh tracking that
down and um and applying a lot of rules
that have developed over a long period
of time around reasonable compensation
to question the validity of that choice
is that right yes uh so this this
threshold is mainly for um any kind of
documentation um that is required um uh
if if the total the compensation that is
paid U is for the personal services is
you know less than
$75,000 the the area would not request
for any kind of documentation to for uh
yeah so I support it thank
you anybody else representative SP yeah
and and just to clarify that it's not
just Dr practices it is our statute that
says in lie of substantiating the value
dot dot dot as a recordkeeping safe
harbor so um you know Medical Practice
uh might be able to justify an a
personal income of 300 or 400,000 who
knows right with
documentation
right uh okay why don't we take a straw
you we'll close the uh work session on
HP
1533 well given that we're making such
great progress today I I had thought we
were going to take a lunch break and
continue but we were going good so we
will finish go to our last
um bill of the day I'll open the work
session on hb1
which is relative to increasing the
amount of the expense deduction allowed
against business profits tax so now and
we've we've asked some questions on on
that we've talked about this one is
pertaining to section
171 of the tax code which um 17 I'm
sorry
um and um it is proposing
to increase the uh total dedu deduction
on an asset
from 500,000 to 1 million and I think at
the federal level as in our previous
discussion we said the federal is
1.16 million was it representative
spillsbury
okay mic oh I'm sorry I'm sorry yes a
milon 160 is the adjustment effective
for tax year
2023 yeah at at the federal level uh
this one
um we were not in line with the federal
level before at 500 I don't believe were
we uh when we first put it at 500,000 I
I I don't recall the um the history on
this okay um but I do know that U on the
federal site right now um the the reason
why the amount keeps increasing year
over year is just because the uh the
threshold on the federal side is
adjusted for inflation whereas on our
New Hampshire statute it's it's a fixed
number interesting okay so when we set
it at
500,000 um I think in
2015 or so some 15 17 somewhere in there
could be yeah I I apologize I don't have
the that's okay my my point is that
there was an inflation adjustment back
then to to 500 but the question or I
don't know how directly it was tied
so to your point of on the federal level
we are tracking or they are tracking
with inflation adjusted amounts uh then
it seems like the appropo to raise this
to to 1 million we don't necessarily
have to mirror them this by putting a
million we're we're just staying at 1
million they may change and we'll have
to readdress this in another legislature
if this if this passes and inflation is
much higher but for now this would only
do that and it's
only
um actually what sort of assets is does
this uh this would
be similar to 68 would be uh personal
property assets so similar like like
Machinery um certain types of Motor
Vehicles right does not apply to real
it's so I can't answer that right
sorry yes repres plat though I agree
with the sentiment of what you just said
uh chairman Janan I'd remove the million
dollar limitation said not to instead
not to exceed that allowed by the
Internal Revenue
code
okay uh representative shamber thank you
Mr chairman a question uh Kean mhm the
is there a top limit on the value of the
property
purchased yes um so
[Music]
the that amount is not uh fixed on the
New Hampshire side so on the it will
follow the federal
amount
yeah so just to clarify so you're saying
this doesn't apply to real estate is
that what you're saying uh no I I
couldn't answer that question at at
right now I need to double check what
did you just say that is uh on the uh
the top level of the the uh the I get I
believe it's the the amount of the cost
of the assets that's been acquired and
assets um representative spillsbury or
anyone else are you familiar as to
whether Section 179 includes real
estate no reading the two bills I was
making that assumption but that I would
like that clarified before we're asked
it just uh see if we can trying to look
well okay I will I'll research that and
provide that answer
okay
um I I know that Keen did email Section
179 to us but uh I don't have it with
me and it was a long Provisions seven or
eight pages it helped me go to sleep
yeah I had to go to the website and look
something
up maybe we just make it easy and tie it
to the federal and be done with it let
it float whatever it's going to float at
which is basically I think what rep PL
said right it's looking to me like you
can't actually you cannot actually depre
according to this cannot actually
depreciate uh actual real property
rental this is a rental example but
rental property uh with Section
179 um doesn't depreciate I've never
heard of yeah actually I have well no no
the uh the building the building the
building so the building is not
depreciable based on this that I just
looked up on 179 I've never never heard
of um depreciating real estate um not
real estate the real estate in the terms
of the building itself um on Section
179 but um yes Mr Wong if you can get us
that answer um possibly um today or by
tomorrow morning we we might end up
executing this uh tomorrow so do do you
think you could have that answer by if
it's helpful the uh one of the uh
attachments that I emailed out uh this
was from the Congressional research
service um within that document um it
does describe the qualified assets so
179 um and to quote that uh
document it um let me see
here the assets are mostly machinery and
equipment used in manufacturing mining
Transportation
Communications uh the generation and
transmission of electricity Gas and
disposal um that's the uh direct quote
from from that document yeah okay so no
no mention of actual yeah the real
estate itself the building yeah so if I
can jump in please yeah uh if we tied
this to the FED I wonder what the impact
would be you know if it was 1168 today
if that wouldn't be too hard to come up
with a number it it seems like that
would be the most logical way to go just
for ease of operation and you know why
do we have to keep coming back well it's
I know I I I'm kind of torn both ways
and I'll tell you why um there's
probably a reason why Dr or or the state
legislature tied our our current tax
code to 2018 probably adjusting every
single year with all the contortions
that go on at the Congressional level
these days um that I I'm I'm kind of I
think more in favor of just setting it
at 1 million right now because you know
it's it's another thing that um Dr has
to track I mean if it starts getting two
out of sync then you know it could be
addressed again but but I do understand
the argument of just tying it to that so
it doesn't have to be addressed um but I
don't know do you have any thoughts on
on that um I well the the adjustment for
inflation is in the uh December 31 tax
Cod December 31 2018 tax code um so if
we were to remove the the uh the a
million dollars or the $500,000 uh
cap uh we essentially just remove that
that
language um at the end of the uh the
statute and then it will just follow uh
whatever Federal number that is being
used um we of obviously we let's say for
audit purposes we would have to know
what is the the uh the cap for that
particular year but uh I believe for
taxpayers um I believe it would be a uh
much easier task for the tax taxpayer
since they're just using the same number
for federal side as well to New
Hampshire side um unless of course if
there's some current change to the
federal law that is uh swaying them away
from the the 2018 law so let's say if
that's a new law that's being enacted
right now federally and changes this
deduction um but we would still be using
the 2018 law and then so if if that Law
changes federally and then if um that
Federal inflation number is not
available anymore then we would have to
figure out what is that infl inflation
number even the taxpayers would have to
figure out what that inflation number is
because if that if federal law doesn't
provide that anymore so that that would
be that complication um having to
well yeah so so the interesting thing
here is what what you're saying is 2018
is a million dollars so if we removed
this limit we would still we would be at
a million uh no if we remove this limit
it will follow uh it would
be yeah it would be that 1.16 1.68 no
but you said we're following the 2018
yes the
2018 incorporates the the language for
inflation adjustment into it yeah okay
no we would still need the accept that
property plac in service um because
that's when we want to start to move it
from the
amount uh wait a minute I'm I'm not sure
what you just said yeah and while Dick's
mulling that over I would just like
anything we can do to simplify taxes for
our constituents for their f is I think
the way to go I mean the tax code I
won't even say what I think about it so
you've already know what I think about
it so any anything we can do to simplify
is good can you uh yeah your um
microphone representative got it the um
additional point I want to make is that
um if once we clarify how we go to this
simpler approach I'd like Dr to
overnight think
about cost and revenue consequences and
not just say well we think it's going to
be a timing issue I don't think it is
for an expense deduction anyway um but
uh i' I'd want to be sure that we're not
stepping over the edge of something and
we don't really know where we're
going you're asking about the revenue
impact going from 500 to a million yeah
we we would not be able to come up with
a with a number on the fiscal impact um
however because as this is a
depreciation again um claiming
that million dollars um Now versus um 5
$1,000 so it's still it'll be a it'll be
a a timing concern okay the only thing
is um as I mentioned earlier if we
follow the federal I mean if we
follow we if we don't have the million
dollar deduction cap and we say okay to
use U the federal number and let's say
if current year now there is some
federal law or maybe in the future
there's some federal law that adjust
adjust the 179 deduction and puts it to
some some other number we might not have
visibility of that um inflation adjusted
number that we would rely on on the
federal side so right now we were we're
relying on the federal uh government to
to publish what is the what is the
inflated adjusted inflation adjusted
number then we're not actually we're not
necessarily
no forget that okay representative PL I
heard you say Mr Wong you do need accept
that for property placed in service
after January 1st 2025 see so that it's
clear when the this takes effect that's
correct but we could change not shall
calculate expense deductions not to
exceed million remove the million and
just say that allowed by the Internal
Revenue code that's
correct so you're saying not to exceed
that allowed by
the we have to say which code the the
code that it would be the 2018 code yeah
because the whole statute is based on
2018 code and with respect to
representative or's comments I'd say
this is a very taxing dis
discussion now in this in this if we
were to change this I don't think we'd
want to say in the 2018 code we would
just say the current IRC adopted by the
state
yeah as of uh as per I think RSA 77- a
think 77- a colon I believe it's
uh XX XX XX a Col one
XX yeah so one is the yes it's
definition section Keen your homework is
to memorize the tax code come in
tomorrow and just you help us out yes
sure all right um representative
spillsbury
yes um K with all of the caveats about
estimating Etc but the significance of
the $4.7 million in the fiscal note is
an estimate of what the tax what the
revenue impact is
Right where's
the where are you seeing the 4.7 million
in the fiscal note it's mentioned at the
bottom of the page the end of the second
paragraph and it's mentioned again uh uh
later on the the next paragraph next
page okay and again I know there are a
lot of caveats but uh isn't that what
you're saying there that a maximum
fiscal impact of 4.7 million is what can
be
expected uh that is up to the I believe
that's when we calculate up to the uh
um right under the bill is drafted at 1
million right yep and the current tax
yeah representative did okay
representative fellows so that actually
was my question also but I'm wondering
so is
this um $4.7
million Revenue lost to the
state is that in the first year but it's
we're talking about depreciation so
aren't we just kind of Shifting it
between yes that's correct yep so it'll
look like a hit the first year but then
we'll it'll be a timing thing yeah okay
well right and then then we hope that
the you know being more business
friendly letting uh companies it would
in entice them to invest more and
potentially you know create additional
business activity so but yeah taxwise
it's a timing issue
it shouldn't change I'm just concerned I
question that logic question which logic
so it it may be true that the timing as
to the asset placed in service you know
in year X becomes neutral over time but
what will happen theoretically is that
this bill induces new investment each
and every year and so that $4.7 million
impact is in fact a recurring in impact
better um I didn't understand that last
part the reoccurring what so so so the
the the the tax neutrality is a matter
of deferral on the assets that can claim
this advantaged
depreciation in this year and that will
the estimate is that that will curtail
state revenue by 4.7 million but it will
occur again next year when more new
assets are placed in service and more
and more of course these
depreciation uh allowances are all
motivated at least conceptually by the
notion that you're going to
constantly incentivize new investment
and replace equipment more rapidly so it
is a constantly recurring thing year to
year and and now you're you're buying
more of whatever widget from somebody
else whose in theory business profits
tax goes up because they're selling more
potentially it's a yeah it's it's a
tough to to have it perfectly zeroed in
yes representative PL I would counter
the argument that representative
spillsbury just made not not not with
factually but uh to say yes but on the
other hand every year following the
investment of that 100 million or
whatever it is there's uh the the
depreciation doesn't occur so the
business profits tax goes up uh be
because there's no more depreciation
stly timing um no matter how often it
occurs if I can offer one final counter
observation
behaviorally in business what often
happens when you allow accelerated
depreciation or you have short like
threeyear what have you is that
businesses will sell their used
equipment after it's fully depreciated
and the buyer of the used equipment now
qualifies to start his own depreciation
all over
what so just just a Contin continuation
of this same discussion so they
depreciate the whole amount the first
year when they and they sell it in the
third year instead of the fifth year so
it should be worth more in the third
year CU it's not as
old so when they sell it that's Revenue
right
so right it
is that's not necessarily Revenue it may
be capital gain if they if it went up in
value it may be Capital loss if it went
down in value and then you get into a
very technical technical area where your
capital gain or loss is adjusted because
of your basis downwards with the
depreciation it's I would say the answer
to your question is you can't generalize
yeah
and as representative spillsbury said it
would allow somebody else to buy the
equipment depreciate it and that creates
more Revenue least somebody else well
yeah but it keeps the cycle going so I
agreed with everything you said except
for the word logic there's no logic in
any of
this repres shamber a question
for Kean Kean uh after the 4.7 million
fiscal impact that you talk
about excuse
me the uh you mentioned without taking
consideration the offset of deductions
or credits taken by the taxpayer in the
year
analyzed do you see or have you seen in
the
past companies taken these deductions
that would add more than what we're
looking at the 4.7 million
yeah those deductions in credits uh
other deductions in other credits not
specifically related to to the asset
itself so in general the business itself
taking deductions and credits in in
other
areas yeah
represent I think we're at a point where
there's General agreement to change this
law uh move from 500,000 I'm a little
unclear on whether this consensus is in
a million or a million something um if
we could
clarify what the
leading members of this Committee in
terms of uh understanding this I think
is best and agree to that then uh okay
let's let's get done with this and get
get an
amendment all right so maybe we ask two
questions here one would be how many you
know like the bill as it is going from
500 to a million and just having an
absolute
number and how many would um like to
have an amendment to this that lines it
with the IRS uh code but we don't know
exactly what the IRS code is going to do
at any any time so so we're g to have
we'll have those two questions first one
is just pass this as is second is an
code well yeah I mean that because that
implies that we could just if you vote
Yes twice then the idea is that we could
just keep this the way it is and not not
amend it because it
does potentially create more uncertainty
not knowing where the IRS is moving so
all right so first first a poll on how
many would just OTP this as is raise
your hand
Jordan is your
yeah uh so all right like 14 to one
representative I no I I I want to I'm a
no because I was going for your second
question modify it so it follows the IRS
that's okay and that's why I asked the
question can you vote Yes twice to help
it I don't think that makes sense I mean
we've made a choice you well I just yeah
I mean
how many how many would prefer we amend
this and follow the IRS
code okay I think it's clear then that
we just go with this as is
OTP thank you there there might be a
third question which is is it ready for
exec
tomorrow um what what would uh make it
not
ready those who still have a question I
mean I'm one of those who's ready to
pass it the way it is yeah well I mean
seeing all the hands off assuming we can
we're ready all right I'm going to close
the uh work session on HB
1536 so we are we are done and that was
a lot quicker than I anticipated I
thought we were going to go to lunch and
come back and uh do that what I would
ask is uh we're done for the day right
we're all we're done for the day yeah uh
so tomorrow as you probably all know
10:00 we will have a work session on the
six bills that were listed and we will
start our exec session at
1:00
um uh tomorrow and uh go from there does
uh anyone have any questions on what
we're doing or just to make sure um were
you thinking we might be able to exec
even more
tomorrow um yes potentially we could EXA
what we talk about in work session
tomorrow we don't need more information
about correct so there's 14 possible
ones I know uh there's already some that
we won't ex but um yeah we could I think
that's a good plan to do as many as we
can thank you exactly yeah um and we'll
probably break you know again I don't
know I mean today we did uh eight by
12:30 I don't know if we can do six by
you know 12 or 11:30 then I'm planning
on a lunch break well a lunch break and
also maybe a little extra time if the
the two parties want to caucus uh
briefly um what I'm planning on doing is
any Republicans here uh let's um you
know take a five minute break and and
come back and and just caucus here um on
need
up